in other news uh President Obama thinks
he would have won this election and pat
i think i agree i think i think anybody
should have been able to beat Donald
Trump anybody other than Hillary Clinton
apparently that's the thing i mean the
democrats decided to nominate the second
most unpopular candidate in our times
right right a second only behind Donald
Trump himself yeah and I mean there were
so many negatives to her he would have
won in a landslide I think he has a 57
approval rating yeah yeah I think he's
absolutely right i mean damn FDR like if
FDR didn't get so greedy with four terms
i mean we could have not had that
legislation maybe Trump maybe Obama
would have won but let's listen to a
minute in his own words this is the
President Obama and he's with David
Axelrod speaking here I think that
Hillary Clinton performed wonderfully
under really tough circumstances the
problem is is that we're not there on
the ground communicating not only the
dry policy aspects of this but that we
care about these communities then we're
bleeding for these communities and that
that we understand why they're
frustrated okay so we have more from
Obama but I want to actually I do want
to talk about that because you know he's
got a point there that's where Democrats
always fought one I can't say always but
more in modern history this is where
Democrats fall short particularly
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton didn't
go to Wisconsin Hillary Clinton didn't
invest time and money in a lot of these
states where she lost and know the
people don't feel like Democrats are
bleeding for them like we don't feel
like that they are out there on the
ground for us we feel like we're numbers
to them and this is where has been
echoed in this election yeah I think
it's safe to say that she lost the
selection in the Rust Belt thought yes
she had some of these states just in her
bag right Wisconsin Pennsylvania
Michigan turns out she lost all three
off all three of them so in this regard
he's absolutely right i think obama
would have won because one he never
would have made that mistake right you
know that that could type of mistake
comes when you are overly confident and
you think you're running as and you're
not running as an underdog you have to
always everything you
you no matter how successful you are if
you ever think that you're not the
underdog then there's an underdog coming
to bite you in that what will apparently
once uh Hillary won the nomination some
of the Bernie people came over to her
team and tried to warn her that the
signs were not looking good in those
Rust Belt states and she would just
ignore it the whole establishment behind
her decided to just stay the course and
not even campaign there for the most
yeah and I was I did want to title this
because it would have been a great catch
phrase to title this Obama thought he
would have won nah Bernie with one right
that's what i wanted to title is would
have won but the truth of the matter is
both of them would have won right Barney
seriously would have won because he
would he runs as an underdog his entire
campaign was speaking directly to the
problems that Obama mentioned in this
clip so Barney would have won Obama
wouldn't want the only person who
couldn't win I think martin O'Malley
could have won only person who couldn't
win was a person that Democrats I'm
sorry I'm still passionate about this
I'm still I'm still amazed that we are
now with President Donald Trump because
Democrats nominated the second most
unpopular candidate in modern history
second only to Donald Trump now here's
the rest of what President Obama said he
said you know I am confident in this
vision because I'm confident that if I
if I had run again and articulated it I
think I could have mobilized majority of
the American people to rally behind it
now he started the entire conversation
speaking good of Hillary Clinton kind of
like oh you know she did good and really
took the other situations but I think
this is more about a Hillary than it is
about Trump I think he's clearly stating
the hillary was not a convincing carrier
of the message he she's not a convincing
messenger yeah he had to play ball there
and you know he adds it yet to say that
Hillary Clinton did her best and did a
good job but that's just party politics
at the end of it I think he definitely
would have won I think you would have
ran a much more economically focused
campaign yeah as Bernie Sanders would
have been I think because he focused on
the economy that's a big reason why
Trump on the election now here's the
problem here's where I think Obama may
not have won is because you can't run a
political economic populist campaign in
your third in your third term when you
didn't do much
about it in the first two terms that's
where the problem is so he could have
beaten Trump absolutely but does he get
a clean slate and able to come in and
say I'm the economic populist who's
concerned about the American people no
not really President Obama as much as I
love you you were a neoliberal who
didn't really take care of the people
that you think you would have one on so
maybe my title would be right that no
Obama you wouldn't want but Bernie
Sanders would have yeah i think that
message kind of worked well for his
reelection campaign at least his first
one in the context because he was able
to market himself as the guy who saved
GM yet also passed the stimulus package
in that the economy was bouncing back
but that third time or ears have not so
much going on it would be a lot harder
so maybe that's the right title for this
clip after all all right